petra sinkova has been missing for
nearly two weeks she's 32 a senior nurse
assistant who police are increasingly
concerned for
forensics officers have been searching
her flat in south london for two days
now and as they hunt for clues others
hunt for information
thank you for coming out local mp
harriet harman among those putting up
posters and handing out flyers as part
of an appeal to find her constituent for
a young woman age 32
to go missing to not go to her work when
she was fully committed to her work and
have not been seen since
we couldn't be more worried
mrs ankova left work at the evelina
london children's hospital at 7 45 pm on
sunday the 28th of november
police believe she traveled by bus to
elephant and castle and then on to her
home in camberwell where she was last
seen at 8 22 she was reported missing by
a colleague five days later police say
petra's disappearance is completely out
of character they've contacted her
family in her native czech republic but
they haven't heard from her either and
so officers family and neighbors all say
they're now extremely concerned
i was
worried because normally we
we speak to each other quite often the
neighbor around here
so
i was worried i didn't think but then
when i started seeing that they were
going in for
checking the house and everything so i
was thinking what's going on well we
haven't heard anything so yesterday i
was even asking the police officer that
i as they had any news about her that
as she
at the founder but you see that he
didn't know so that was about it
a man has been arrested in connection
with petra's disappearance and is
currently in custody while police appeal
for anyone with any information to come
forward
iva bennett sky news camberwell